Alex Jones is turning on Trump and Trump
supporters and I have to tell you this
broken clocks you know the entire thing
Alex Jones analysis of Trump's Tuesday
night rant at Mar-A-Lago
actually is quite accurately assessing
the reality of trump and his own
supporters I'll just play it for you
Alex Jones is making a lot of sense here
okay other than this noise he's making a
lot of sense thank you oh
that's not the sound I want to hear
this is one of my big irritants with
high-level Trump supporters they're in
there drinking it's a big carnival they
love being near the president they love
the fancy beautiful architecture yeah
and they just it's like a beauty pageant
or something like they feel like they've
arrived I've seen it I've been around it
and there is just a delirium and the
same thing happened as rallies oh we're
Invincible oh we can't be stopped it was
just drove me crazy
sometimes there's two minutes of
applause
and and whooping and hollering and you
just it's like they're having fun this
is not fun
I've just been around the Trump people
and around Trump when there's people
around and everybody's like oh hi and I
can't believe they're there and oh it's
like they're in the cool kid club and
I've been saying that
for six years but he never did it
all right so I have to tell you Alex
Jones is completely correct there is a
delirium in the room at these events
like the one at Mar-A-Lago on Tuesday
the vibe at Mar-A-Lago we were watching
it for like an hour before Trump spoke
we could see what was going on
it was like you were there for something
positive and I know some of them are
trying to spin it into the indictment is
good because it means Trump is going to
win it might help him in the primary I
don't think it helps them with even a
single new vote in the general election
if he makes it that far but there is
again we just talked about cult-like
it's cult-like and Alex Jones knows
about cults he's tried to build one I
mean the Infowars audience is not
exactly clear thinking but he is
completely correct that it why is there
a party atmosphere at Mar-A-Lago he's
been accused of 34 felonies there are
more allegations coming now I know they
just write it off they say this is all
just bogus but there is a Detachment
from reality a delirium really is the is
the best word for it that Alex Jones
accurately points out and I I almost
think Trump can get sentenced to prison
and he would be turning himself over to
start his sentence
and they would have a party and cheer
because somehow some cult leader would
tell them this is actually a good thing
and I'll tell you why it's bizarre to
see let's hope that it leads to their
own destruction electorally in 2024.
we've got a pact program today glad
you're here quick break and then it
continues